and
we can go ahead and go live
okay for people who are joining this
live stream this is
one of a large stream of design reviews
that we will be doing
for version 12.3 which is approaching
rapidly
uh all right we had started looking at
this
previously um we're looking at
sound and vision um
have we looked at this before is this
our first no we we'd looked at this
previously right this is a second
okay all right so where are we starting
today from the agenda we went down to
bitrate
on their editing around there but we
have to go back to video generator
okay um if you recall last time we
talked about the start and end
specification just to generate specific
frames
we would like to propose a second
function um
alongside this and that is called video
frame generator
if you open that one as well then we can
discuss why
so video frame generator is a friend of
video frame list
somehow yes
so the idea is simply to take if you
want
sort of if you're frame oriented let's
say that you're constructing them
and you want to be able to really
control how your function is being
called
then the video frame generator is the
more natural one to use okay but
but basically what this is is the analog
of
of list play
right this is this is taking a function
and it is doing a table
but there's a huge difference let's say
do you have 2 000 of these to generate
if you have a list of 2 000 high
resolution images
in memory which you will have
that's very hard to do i don't care i
mean that's a different function name i
i
i don't care what i mean what is your
point what's your point roger
the way that it works is not okay it's
going to do it out of core
that's what it should do right that's
what you're saying no
this play takes a list of images oh no
no what are you talking about list play
doesn't do anything that's list animate
okay okay roger we're not doing this
thing of inventing a whole new family of
functions
just because you don't like the way
other functions work we are going to
make a bridge between them we are not
having
a bunch of separate functions we're
doing these things right the big
problem that ended up happening when you
add step to video generator
is that you effectively have two
different frame rates
i i understand i understand so what we
need to do is understand
list animate we need to understand how
list animate merges
with video frame generator okay because
those aren't compatible
right now list animate is doing the same
thing
except that it is what is it generating
is it generating a video or is it
generating something else
okay all right so but but the concept
here
is okay so this is taking an explicit
list
whereas this is taking essentially a
table construct right
yes
i mean i'm wondering if this should be
called something like video frame
table or something that's not quite
right i propose that as well
that seems reasonable to me
personally i find these generator
functions really confusing
and i don't even use it the audio
generator i found completely confusing
and i find myself using
you know play instead of the audio
generator
so let's take a look at why i find the
audio generator confusing
okay i think the main reason is that we
put the function usage which is the one
that you would gravitate naturally
last in the documentation that might
have been a mistake
by the way i've reported this about
eight times
this this business with this this you
know weird flowing
what of auto completion here that needs
to be fixed does somebody know that that
needs to be fixed
or do i need to go re-emphasize it
uh scott i think that's what if it's
reported but i'll make sure
make sure you report it and make sure
that it's in if nothing else that's in
the next user assistance meeting
okay i just don't understand this at all
i mean i just i i think this design is
awful
okay frankly go ahead go on what are we
going to do
so the justification of that is to
provide
people coming from synthesis-oriented
audio backgrounds uh some shortcuts
instead of having to explicitly write a
function uh they could just
say i want a sinusoidal oscillator or a
square oscillator or whatever
i know in retrospect as i said you that
model can
easily be a function that's the second
example um
and as i said that probably was a
mistake to document that
as something in the notes in the details
of options
rather than something very expensive
it's wrong yeah it's wrong you can't do
that yeah right you shouldn't do that so
i think what we should do here is change
this
not even
you know
what we really have here
yes i think that's right i think what
what needs to happen is
the default needs to be a function
what is this like what what what other
kind of thing do we have like this
because you know something like plot
or play for that matter i mean the
relationship between this and play
is incomprehensible
right because that's what play would do
right
and that to me makes perfect
now why is this a function
you see what i'm saying what why is that
what's what's why is this thing
why isn't it not the case that play
generates audio objects
first of all
i mean okay yes that is something you
cannot easily and you can do
already by saying audio of the output of
that but yes
but that's that's that's that tight
connection of
how sound the old sound and new audio
should connect hasn't happened yet i've
said that repeatedly i
i think the right time to do that is
when we have more symbolic
sound as well right but we can fix this
right now
we could make play generate an audio
object couldn't we
definitely if if uin users are happy
with the backwards incompatibility
sure why is that backwards
incompatibility because then the object
that comes back is not a sound object
it's an audio object
i hate this this was a sloppy piece of
design guys
really sloppy that's nice i don't think
it's sloppy audio generator is a little
bit too low
level i think that there's
there is room for higher level
look this function is basically the same
as this function
it just has some named models in it
which are useful
as well as the processes and time series
and so forth but yeah the the function
case of it is the same
well but i think those are wrong too i
don't think that's
see this is it's just wrong if you have
a time series it's an explicit
well how to think about this no time
series is not
uniformly sampled
cannot assume that what this is doing
is just like
play takes a function it samples it at
particular values
it uses that to generate the sound
amplitude right
that's what this is doing as well
right i think play as well normalizes
right carlo
there was something here intrinsic with
the sound object not we'd play
specifically yeah okay well fine so
there's some issues with that
i mean that's the audio what is it play
range or something
analogous to plot range i mean that
stuff is all 30 years old
yep built in 1989. thank goodness we
built
it then i didn't wait for 30 years to do
it
i do not like these cases where you try
and overrun
you know where you try and just have a
new generation of functions it does not
work
it will eventually break so look this
audio generator thing
you know we need to integrate it with
play
i mean can we agree here that we change
play to return audio
yes although probably not instantly
because i'm worried about
incompatibility issues
but that will be the goal yes but then
what i think we should do
see my question is would it make sense
to allow that see
we have a whole okay
the intent is for audio generator to
take a whole filter graph and things
so that model will get a whole lot more
sophisticated over time
okay but i don't i i i
okay so like you can have a digital
filter
along with these is that correct yes
okay a filter graph can have more
generators inside of it
you can have you you know you can have
another signal that modulates
another signal that's usually how you
get i understand that i understand so
it's like a neural net
like that kind of architecture which by
the way it's a bag yeah
yeah right but by the way we're going
away from that architecture and towards
something more procedural
sort of but that's only really for for
a generated distribution
right okay i i don't think this is look
i think what we need to do
in terms of of how this
i just don't think this function is the
right function i think it's too low
i've said so all along okay i think it's
too low level
it's just not directly usable the way
it's configured
right well so let's not repeat the
mistake with video
okay i mean we're going to need to
separately come back and design this
audio thing and i think
my my belief is
you know i don't know maybe there's an
audio generator or something that's
really confusing but
i don't know what it is i don't know um
you know i can imagine i mean play is a
very nice simple function
that's very easy to understand we change
it over to use audio and we have it yes
but not today because i don't think we
know what consequences it has fine
right but yes okay but then you have it
then then we don't need to talk more
about play because you have it
no that's not correct we need to move
all these kinds of things into play and
out of here
really yes because we don't want
this this is unusable so we need to
figure out how we make it more usable so
for example
i think that having a audio to me
there's this notion of an audio
generator function
right which is something like a triangle
wave
and i would like to be able to play a
triangle wave
between this time and this time and then
that time to that time and so on
right the thing is this is sort of a
backwards way to do it
because what should have happened is
this shouldn't be something where we
stuff them into
a general audio generator function i
mean or
oh boy this is such a mess you know what
we want is something where
i would have thought
i mean i never like these things here
this way
oh it's the right way to do this
you can potentially just undocument
these uh
named models because you can get
everything you can just put sine of a
thousand hash
although that's a pure function
no but we look getting a triangle wave
is useful
i just think this is a grotesque way to
do it
and i'm i'm asking myself the question
why is there not a function that simply
there is there's a sort of wave function
there is a tree yeah
triangle wave as well so what earth are
we doing here
what are we doing
what is this
again the named ones are just shortcuts
with some predefined frequencies that
make sense for audio what about pulse
we don't okay so we need that
but we have square wave yes yes
i think this is very much the wrong
design
you know okay anyway we'll come back to
this
okay can you guys take a look at this
and that
merging this into play and then play
giving audio
okay
i think that having it be able to play a
random process is nice
if that i mean so if if we say something
like random walk process
here and define the process
and then i say six or something no what
what how do i get the actual random
variate
random function
okay so i have to say random function
and then what do i do
for how long what's that other thing
there
got that
okay so what is that doing so then then
what i should be able to do no that
should have generated something
i you know zero to six or something
yeah might want it a little bit longer
what is this what is this this is not a
time series what is it
it's temporal data what does that mean
it means it's temporal data it means it
has a time component and it has a value
component
it can start this is the foundation for
time series time series are temporal
data i know i know i don't like that
because i know you don't like that but
this can represent multiple
if you want 10 of often you need a whole
ensemble of these if you're going to
represent
in data what the random process
represents you need multi
you know you don't have them so what is
the difference so if i'm going to play
this
i just want one instance don't i i'm not
fine
unless i'm unless i'm you know going
unless you're doing statistics of it
no no no no no no if i'm playing it i
just want one of it so you don't do
statistics of it
you're just playing it okay so and you
just transition
so i should say audio generator of this
is that correct
i think just the random work profit
process you don't need i know i know i
know it's a mess
it's wrong because here you've got the
actual function you're giving
see what i'm saying but not for how long
the same thing no that is not that is
just
the shape of the function is not an
explanative function at all
that sine function doesn't say for how
long it lasts
okay so here we're saying by default
okay so for here instead of giving 0 to
10 which i had to give there
i just give 10 for some reason does it
start at zero does it start at one
yes the time always starts at zero
but if i gave 0 to 10 here it would fail
yes only the duration is specified as
the second argument but for some reason
random function
it has a two argument form there
i see exactly the problem we're trying
to solve
for video generator and video frame
generator that you're trying to solve
here
sometimes you really want to specify the
function parameter range
sometimes you want to specify the
duration
yeah okay all right
so let's go through what we've got here
okay
so the thing that we want one thing we
want
is something which has a function that
generates
video frames what is the other
the other thing you might want is
um
uh in addition to generating video
frames
you're taking something where you are
sampling every so often
something is that correct i mean one
thing is i'm going to tell you what
sample points are is that right
yes but i'm going to tell you two things
i'm going to tell you what time that
sample is taken at
and what the sample is or am i telling
you frame by frame by frame what i'm
going to what i'm supposed to give
that is frame by frame by frame
okay like like table you specify what
each element of the table is
okay and then the other case i'm saying
i've got this thing and it's up to the
video system itself
to decide where to sample it is that
correct yes
okay and in the case of so in play for
example it's up to play to decide where
to sample
right yes we just give you the range
not not the exact points to sample
based on this example in the audio case
what is the
analog i mean list play is the thing
that gives you
right so if i say list play sine
you know whatever it is t 0 1
10 to the minus i mean 0.001 like this
i don't think so i think you just give
it samples so if you say listen
that's what that's what we want yes
sorry sorry so i want this
basically but i'm not giving it a time
basis all right i'm not giving it the
time base
for this i'm i'm just saying here if i
were to give this
and that's somewhat reasonable for audio
but it's not very reasonable for audio
either if you're going to do something
of any length
i have no idea what this just did what
did you do
i put t comma this i think you
created a 1000 channel
sound i'm not sure
okay okay fine of length two examples
okay all right that was goofy
um okay but so
in the video case what you're saying is
one thing is i'm generating frames
the other thing is i've got this thing
that is going to give me the state of
the video
and then the generator is going to pick
you know 30 frames a second out of that
is that correct yes that seems correct
and in the first case where i'm giving
frame information
okay this there's a third case the third
case is
it's this kind of stop-motion animation
where i'm telling you
at this second i've got this at this
second i've got this
whatever where i'm giving you the time
value
and where i've got you know the time
and the instantaneous frame and then
you're going to either interpolate
between those
or just do stop-motion type stuff is
that right
i don't we don't have that but that
could be sort of a variant of
which manipulate saying with your finite
number of parameters and then you're
interpolating those parameters
i didn't understand that the i mean so
if you say
like stop-motion okay yeah okay let's
say that you have 10 parameters in the
manipulate
and for each set of parameter values you
get a
2d graphic let's say now if you say
here is what it is here then you you
have another snapshot of parameter
values yeah yeah
why are you talking about manipulating
it's analogous but you're not suggesting
we actually use manipulate for that
no i end you know i something very
similar in just okay okay i understand
yes but where you tell
sort of how those different parameters i
agree with you yes i agree with you
manipulate it has a step
it has a dx but the step
but no no no no roger roger it's not
correct it's not correct what you said
i was right no no i was just correcting
what you were saying
yeah right what i'm saying is there's a
there's a thing
in which what we would have is a time
series
of video you know a time series of
frames
that's another case right the time
series of frames yeah so i have a whole
family of these generators
so one thing is that it could be a
slideshow
okay because it probably doesn't make
sense to interpolate between
frames you see in that case it doesn't
right right so a slideshow and possibly
transitions
makes a lot of sense it's a common case
i'm sorry without transitions or with
transitions well either way
both with or without okay so
so different from list of frames list of
frames is uniform
uniform list of frames okay well
the list you could tell when when the
frame let's start yeah
list of frames with well that's the time
series of frames
yep right
and you could even have video segments
in there it could be static frames
and then a video you know
i see i see i see mixed
frames and video so that is analogous to
what we have a sound and sound
note right where that has a way of
placing
the time for a particular sound note and
so on
right remember that
yeah so do we have a similar thing for
video and audio so when you
when you have audios how do they get
placed if you have
an audio and then you want another audio
so you say hello
and then you've got a you know then you
want to say it there
and that there wants to come you know
500 milliseconds later
how do you do that so audio is kind of
similar to
how you place images right you trim and
you plow the new crop and you join
okay so it's a it doesn't have
a like graphics it doesn't have sort of
a position me in this place
which we probably want one piece audio
no but it's it's like a list i mean it
has the same kind of behavior as a list
where
to position things in a list you just
have to put more list elements to get it
there
yes so
an alternative is the sort of floating
positioning like we have in graphics
right or like we have in sound
i mean what we do with sound notes is
similar to what we do with graphics
and within sets and so on right
i think so i'm i'm not sure if you want
to complicate
audio that's where i say i think sound
is a great container for all of these
um more flexible ways of creating i
agree so what do you think
right so what we're saying is that sound
should be able to contain audio objects
where you are specifying with sound like
graphics
you're specifying kind of the symbolic
level thing
which could contain lumps that are like
rasters
you know like an inset raster for
example similarly
i mean we already have that right we
have a set what is it called the sampled
sound object
right sample sound list yeah sample
soundless should presumably go away and
which will just be replaced by audio is
that correct
yeah we could do that i think that's
what we should do we should plan to
deprecate that
and replace it with audio okay it's
served well for 30 years we can we can
easily provide a transition but we do
not need to continue
to enhance that particular thing
um okay so that's sampled sound list and
that's so that's
that's the way that we think about it so
for video
we do not have the outer container so
sound is the outer container for audio
am i making sense yeah
so so don't have a similar outer
container for video
right well you're right maybe we should
get a symbolic outer container
that would provide for editing and other
things
but we can still build functions that
produce you know
even if we didn't have that outer
container one can still
build functions to take similar sort of
input specifications and produce
a video yes i understand but the video
i mean where essentially what we're
doing is to produce the equivalent of
rasterized of sampled sound we're
producing
a an every frame video we don't have a
symbolic representation of the slideshow
that's right right so what we should
have probably is the symbolic
representation of the slideshow
so what we need is what would be if
audio is to sound
video is to movie probably
is that right it's not quite right i
don't think so
well okay audio is to sound as video is
too blank
and i'm not aware of a format that does
that
except possibly
uh flash had something along those lines
i i think probably if you dig in the
interactive tools for video editing
allow right the internal specific
storage of the project yeah
um
ethan is commenting video data like
images you know this is the other way
around this is making it more symbolic
so this is taking
a lump of video which is essentially a
raster where
every frame it's a full you know dense
list of frames
and then we want to be able to place
that dense list of frames at this moment
at that moment
another moment um
now unfortunately with whereas with
sound we can perfectly well have
superposition we have chords
there is no obvious way to make a chord
with video
is that well there's overlays
yeah but it's pretty weird but i think
with video editing i mean i guess people
do that with video editing like they
have layers
yep
all right so we need a name for the
outer wrapper we don't know what it is
movie is a possible related name okay
so for these inner things what you're
saying right now
is that
we need something which is the
equivalent of play
for a video no
the equivalent of this this is the thing
which will generate which will go from
which has a function that generates a
video frame list
correct so this works exactly like table
that's
just a normal expression i know not a
function
i know i know i know i realize that so
which means it's working like play yes
yes yep okay except well actually it
isn't working like play because
it it's well wait a minute is it
so confused yeah no it isn't because
play goes from zero to one
and it is responsible for sampling in
that rate
range
that's right right this one is
also uh responsible for sampling
because you're not going to generate a
frame unless you it's in that
iterator okay let me understand there
are two different possibilities
okay so one thing would be um
i mean
you know this concept of a slideshow
i don't know we won't have that actual
name but okay so what would the
slideshow be so a slideshow
i mean here's a possibility we could
have a slideshow video
and that what that does is you give it a
list of list of images
and it returns a video
that seems like not a completely stupid
thing to have and we could decorate that
by turning this into a time series or
some junior time
series which has you know times and then
we could have transitions and all kinds
of things like that
that was the idea basically that's one
of their generators yes
yeah currently that it that is in video
generator
released last release 12-2
okay except nobody will ever find no
that's it's not a
practical version of that
right i mean this is a totally bizarre
complicated messy thing
so i think this this seems like a good
idea slideshow video it's pretty easy to
understand what it is
um david is on the suggesting flipbook
yeah you know we had a flipbook
capability in version one
only 33 years ago
um but it wasn't didn't generate videos
it was a thing that
allowed you to make to print out a flip
book i think i still even have some of
those they had to be had some molecular
visualizations
in flip books okay so anyway slideshow
video seems like a winning thing
now the other case is
that's okay video produces this comment
from gekko here
about um but this what i had in mind for
this
is the default would be the default for
this would be a one second
default eg one second per slide
you see what i'm saying yep right so
that's not
here's a list of frames i'm going to
make i've got
okay so the other that's one case is the
slow shot slideshow
right okay so the second case
is and there's no function here it's
just a list you've already got pre-made
the list and the point is to generate a
video from
a list of images
i mean we could also call it images
video
but like images itself it doesn't have
to be images presumably so
it could be i see it could be graphics
or something
right yeah so this is this is a very
useful function this is a good thing to
have
this is this is this was very much on
our list okay
okay so slideshow video becomes one
thing okay so then the other one
would be and i hate to i mean you know
this is too weird
but the other one is essentially this is
too weird because that's
it's assuming too much but what that but
we understand what this
what this is no you see that's not right
okay so another function would be this
would be the
full speed video by default full speed
oops full speed video so this one the
default is
some known you know
slideshow rate this one would be
this is the rawest of frames or is that
simply video itself what happens if i
say video of a list of frames
that's not that that we have discussed a
couple of times it's not supported
export currently can do that you can
export the list of images
get a file and then say video of that
that's silly
why don't we just do this why don't we
just have video of the list of images
just work
um carlo we discussed this a couple of
times
i think the reasons we avoided that was
that then we had to add
options such as frame rate as a very
natural thing to specify
and in all other cases where we say
video of a file
those properties are already intrinsic
in the file right okay but we need a way
to get and this seems natural
i mean look we could do no no no well we
could do a default frame rate
here i mean we do have a frame rate
option right
we do have a frame rate option what is
that an option too
well video generator is one okay so then
let's just have it be an option to video
but but then as i said if you pass video
a file
which is i already has it it already has
it yep
i mean we you might want to re-sample it
a different frame rate and that would be
a way to do it
well then you have to transcode the
whole video though and i'm not sure if
just the specification of a frame rate
option should invoke
a complete transcoding i don't know
that's a separate that's a separate
issue
right it's a separate issue but in this
case video of a list of
images with a frame rate could just do
this flip book type video
seems like the natural way to do it and
it should have a default frame rate
i don't think that's going to be a
terribly popular thing to do
okay i think slideshow is going to be
more popular
okay so then can we not add this yet
i'll make a note of it
yeah with the slideshow video
unless but if we're going to call it
slideshow video it has an implication of
a slow video if you understand what i'm
saying
i do
but i like the idea of having some of
these named types of videos
yeah we have discussed it a lot as well
roger also thinks video generator
still video frame generator are lower
level functions
and their functions i don't care about
because i think they're too
they're so hard to understand it doesn't
matter
we should we should figure out what we
actually want to do and then we'll
figure out what low-level function will
support it
i think they're hacky not general enough
and incomprehensible
do i need to add any further adjectives
my argument is then what is your opinion
table right video frame generator is
syntactic syntactic exactly the same
this is why i'm
kind of it's a video generator i agree
that is
yes video frame generator however we try
to
have it much closer to okay
i understand so we may want that
function but that name is a loser
yeah okay that there is a very fair
objection okay it could be the
time table okay so let's let's think
about what that should be
because
i mean by the way there are all kinds of
interesting things one could imagine
with a slideshow video
like for example annotating with audio
right
for example one thing you might want to
do is have an audio
and have the slide play you know slide
be up there
for the time that the audio is speaking
do you understand what i'm saying
ah where am i going i need to go here
where is my section for this do i have
one for video
yes
okay
so um we've got a number of comments on
the live stream which i
think um i just want to look at these
for a second
comment from ethan please add the
ability to skip to specific
times in the play gui for
or sound i think he's saying that for
the sound gui
do we have it for this one uh yes the uh
uh position slider next to the play
button allows you to jump
forward i see i see i see i see i see i
think that's what he's asking for
okay i think that the very reason the
sound it's a very reasonable thing and
the sound
play the sound play thing should be
unified with this
gui insofar as it's staying
yep okay that's that one all right
nick is saying cool to generate videos
just by applying some animation effects
to graphics
yes that's another family of several of
those families we've also talked about
and he's suggesting it for the summer
school and it's a good idea and it
should be added to the list of student
projects thank you for the suggestion
hold on before i forget this i'm going
to add it
um let's see
uh
right
and uh hold on one second just before i
forget
since not really confident
[Music]
who is who is doing notes and things in
this meeting
i am okay
okay uh ethan is saying we
need scrubbing for audio play what we
have that don't we
no we don't this doesn't this scrubbing
is like for the vinyl record where you
can pull it back and
and hear more stuff right
is that right or am i wrong i'm not sure
what you're talking about you you move
this and as you move the slider it is
still continuously playing
from wherever the slider gets to yeah i
think that's
that's what it is and we don't have it
we should have it
i'll make it note right
um is it really a high priority for us
to have it
not particularly no i think it's an
interesting thing to have i think it's a
useful thing to have
um
okay um
so should i show frame show
ah there's questions about in memory
stuff which is not going to work
i think i mean we agree and memory is
not going to work
ethan is commenting with kernel crashes
when attempting to accumulate high-res
frames for video and memory yeah look in
memory case is just not
not a not a winner but that's presumably
your video frame generator is not
accumulating in memory no nothing is
nothing is in memory unless you try to
parallelize it then
it does little batches in memory and
then writes it down okay so it's doing
the right thing
is basically the point yes um jimmy is
commenting here
options frames per image frames per
second
default being image per second
frames per image
i see for your slideshow video i think
yes yes yes yes
frames per image yeah that is
a slightly tricky thing right because
that that is correct that's that's the
way to think about it so i mean i would
say that the obvious thing to do
is to have a dt there as the second
argument
and to use on the other hand was
thinking something like t1 image one t2
image two specifications
absolutely you should also be able to do
that but the default should be something
like this
but then i would say that the other
possibility would be
that you could have a t1
you know like a list plot t1 image one
t2 image2 exactly
series of images it can be a time series
of images as well
and i think also you should be able to
have audio
which defines a time obviously image one
audio image two
and that way it'll be and this is our
amazing
whatever it is so that's a little
different that means
duration stan
well that's what these would be as well
this would be durations you don't want
to have an absolute time
no you do not want absolute times okay
there's a dt1 dt2
you want to say i want this slide up for
one second i want that slide up for two
seconds
okay so it definitely is not time
serious no
it's definitely not well okay but then
the other case
would be i would say slideshow video
of a time series where it knows it's a
time series
and it knows that those are absolute
time settings
okay i admit this is different from list
plots here
yes but this is still i think the right
thing to do
unless i think so too i think it makes
it modular
you can easily slot something else in
right
um yeah i think this is a very useful
thing
honestly in the second argument i'm not
sure of
in general i agree this is useful
details of the design we can work out
well i mean
then then the other possibility would be
but see remember you're going to have a
frame rate here
but the frame rate has nothing to do
with the rate of slides
i mean there will be a slide rate but
that's different
right that will be that's the dt there
yes
yeah i guess the question is what do you
do when that conflicts with the explicit
dt1 dt2 except there are specifications
i don't know
you pick one or the other you probably
picked the explicit yeah no
actually actually no the obvious thing
to do is to pick the bank switch one
because that will then overwrite those
right that will be the thing you might
want to do somebody might have given you
one of these things with a bunch of gt1s
dt2s
then you might say i don't want that i
just want them all at one second
i'm telling you it's not going to be
obvious what that number should be
because not everybody is going to want
one second
or even i don't even think one second is
right i think i don't know what the
default is that people use
probably half a second or something
um not sure really depends on the
content as well as
depends on many things right on many
things yeah
but this is this i think it's fantastic
you can do like 7
000 slideshows in an hour slide slides
in an hour
if what half a second okay
yeah well that's that's a that's the
kind of talk i'd like to
i like
um okay
so let's come back then to the video
frame generator case
okay so that case is a little bit of a
different okay so this is case number
one slideshow video
another case is the full speed video um
and then the other case is
um
okay i've got a possible idea frame
table video
and so then what that would be is your
function
and then your
probably shouldn't be t because it's no
it isn't t it's just n
or i or whatever i think i think what we
have in
video frame generator is exactly what
you want
yep that that's just the table syntax
fine what do you think of frame table
video
then we got a family basically where
it's blah blah blah video
which means make a video from some kind
of source
seems like it's understandable
do we have video as a second argument of
of things yet
no good
i think this is a winning idea okay so
now what other functionality does
okay so that's video frame generator and
this
is so it is
this is a full rate video correct
or could i put in something which turns
this into a slideshow with a dt
no that is a full frame video it's like
saying
like your first case of video of list of
images
uh if that was just a symbolic table
specification
so you know this will be a possibility
frame table video and frame list video
so the one the one issue that i have
with this
uh frameless video and the slideshow one
is that
they require to have in memory already
all of the images
which in some contexts can be initially
allow it to be files i mean allow this
thing to take
files
i mean why not just have something where
those where those things there can be
file of blah blah anyway we have the co
or a dynamic image for example why not
dynamic image
right
now i mean just so i understand if these
images are all different sizes
different you know pixel sizes
this will conform those images correct
uh at the moment only if you do uh
specifying
an explicit last raster size um
but which i think it should i think it
should change i think by default it
should probably use the first
image okay and do that do it that way
that's yeah we can use it that's
reasonable and and currently we always
image resize which means stretching in
whatever direction
um we are down down in the agenda there
is a frame fitting option
that potentially we can add to these
functions i think that that needs to
happen yeah but i think
okay listen i'm i'm liking these
functions slide your video it's pretty
easy to understand what that means
frame table video it's
you know it's a thing frame list video i
think that's fairly easy to understand
however frame list video is just
slideshow video with a dt that is one
over sample rate right that is correct
that's correct
but i think it's useful i don't think
there should be merge but it should
definitely not be merged
because slideshow you want to evolve in
a different direction
with transitions and all kinds of things
and you really don't want that for frame
this video ever
right exactly yeah but frameless video
if you wanted something there you might
want
go ahead what are you going to say i'm
still unconvinced this is
also exactly the same as video of list
of images that you have
three lines above i know if we did that
we could but then then we could avoid
doing that and just have frameless video
be the thing but what
what other functionality does video
frame okay video frame generator
is then the same here as frame table
video
right but video generator is what
combines the play version
of all of these with the single image
list of image case look at the second
table
in the details
generate a second of a single image
or a list of images or an image function
[Music]
okay i'm totally confused by this
just totally confused
i i'm just totally confused by this
okay there's a plot what the heck is it
doing
it's sampling that plot
30 times from zero to one
i just think this is crazy i mean
because
i would the fact that it's one second i
think is weird
i don't think that i think that default
is fine for demos but i think it's
useless for reality
you know i think what it would like
having play have a default of one second
which would also be crazy
you know play i mean look play is an
easy to understand
you know thing and this is the analog of
play
right except that it has a function here
correct
yes
so i mean there's a in some sense this
is like frame
function video it's not a very good name
where
well that would be the kind of the the
concept
where instead of at being a table
so so this is like this is
analogous to animate right
yes
because animate takes an expression
so let's take i don't know something
like rotate
a
i don't know how this works if i do that
um
okay so animate is not
do i need the point one there or not
no i don't so it's
it's choosing the sampling right
correct correct okay
so the only difference so what you are
proposing
is a function which does this basically
brilliant what's that all about
that's prototype build i don't know but
animate
producing and manipulate should be
wow oh that might be the progress
indicator it's the progress center
yes okay bug in the progress indicator
okay so let's play this and see whether
we got what we wanted
okay so it has that crazy crazy what why
is that all that wiggling going on
and why does it generate do we really
want this
showing the actual
i see so really what we're doing here is
we want something that's like animation
video
right and if we said that we would say
you know
the the what it would look like is just
something like this so it's the analog
of animate except that it doesn't give
you
a slider and so on it returns a video
that seems like a not totally terrible
design
so there'd be a frameless video go ahead
one question
those two are the second argument second
and third argument in the second one
uh t010 are those start and end times
of the real time in the end
product of the video or are those
arbitrary numbers that are just used to
be passed to the expression
and then the actual times of the frames
are determined
what we did with play is those are the
absolute times
okay so there is no place for a step
specification in this
well there is yes there is there is
there is you just say comma
you know however one one okay thirtieth
of a second or something but then you
the frame rate option we becomes
unnecessary
is what you're saying oh i don't know if
the frame rate becomes unnecessary i
mean you might want to re-sample somehow
i mean that's a separate issue what the
what the step sizes and what the frame
rate is i think are separate issues
okay but these are all real times of the
output video it's not i think so that
worked i mean for 30 years that's worked
really well with play it's pretty easy
to understand
and it's pretty easy you know if you
want something which is i don't know
100 times a second or something you just
put it in
what happens with play if i do t
from 10 to 20. does it give silence for
10 seconds then
let's find out
10 to 20 yeah okay
no it doesn't okay it starts at the
beginning which is
so it translates that whole thing back
in time
yeah zero yes yes it does
not completely crazy
look it does the same as plot does it is
modeled directly after plot right so if
i say plot
x 10 to 20 right
it still starts there
okay for animation video clearly
one needs and i think you had a syntax
for that here the possibility of having
an audio and a video
right we do
and our main conclusion has been that
it's
more useful to use video combined
separately i
suspect you're right i suspect you're
right
because i think that this that i mean
this is a very weird case
what you would do be doing here is you'd
be having a play i can imagine some
scientific type places where this would
be useful
right where you have a i don't know
you're doing you know a bifurcation
diagram
you want both the audio playing and
a video of what's going on or something
i can imagine that
but then you see that this step all of a
sudden becomes very weird as well
you most of the time do not want to
generate samples for audio video at the
same
rate i agree i agree so in that case
it's a mess
yeah okay i think that the audio case
here is weird
yep i mean so but i don't think that's
the important thing i think the
important thing i think you're right
roger
that combining um
i think this is a good function that
people can actually understand
yeah i think both of these slideshow
video and animation video both
sensible frame table video what time
i think i agree with you i think that
the list of of
very usable generators is longer than
this we had a longer list
so fine but then we should get those now
what are we doing with frame table video
why is frame table video usefully
different
from i see animation video that's a real
number
so people were very frame oriented you
and i think sandoz if i remember
last time yeah sandor sorry and
um it's it's legit uh we we talked about
it and i think we think it's
it's kind of legit let's make something
that makes that really clean and clear
okay so the other possibility would be
animation list
yeah i don't like that i think frameless
video is sensible
i think that's the inverse of video
frame list so to speak
um
let's see
uh is a buffering going on i don't know
i mean there's what kind of buffering i
mean that there's a whole complicated
thing for playing
stuff um
uh okay apparently people want to hear
about geometry don't we have a geometry
one of these coming up pretty soon we do
yes
it is on if the calendar doesn't change
see it for this week it's it's it's um
noon
uh 12 central time tomorrow oh discrete
computation
okay is it it's geometry graphics
okay we're running over the time for a
different meeting but but
okay so i think we've made really good
progress here so but let's go back
to what we're looking at over here and
we've still got quite a few things left
to do here
right how much of this stuff is probably
pretty straightforward yes
yes yeah i want to see the thread
analysis for this that's
highly that's something i really care
about i know i unfortunately i don't
think that's gonna make it again this
this round okay do we know the design
yes
do you have anything even experimental
no
okay
um
what does that mean label matrices what
does that mean
like the segmentation the semantic
segmentation result highlighted
a different color on the image if you
open highlight image there is an example
you have a type of spelling yes
scroll down you're saying basically if i
have a
a cat and a dog in the picture one of
them is supposed to be highlighted one
color and one the other color
is that the type not as a not as a
bounding box but if you have um
the the addition is if you have a label
matrix an
integer label matrix um
that says all of my label ones are
the cat or the cats label two or the
other object typical label matrix as
in in in the the so
pixel segmentation right so okay so that
that's a highlight region of image so if
i had a list of images here i see not a
list of images
how do you go from a list of images to a
label matrix
that we don't have but from that binary
image morphological components
will give you a label matrix and then
that could be fed into highlight image
and we have a large collection of
segmentations as well as neural nets in
the repo
do we want to like like we have net
model do we how do
how do you specify a segmentation
i mean in other words is there an easy
way if i want to take some random
you know there's something goofy about
the fact that that's a capital letter
and these ones aren't
i bet that's my fault from having
specified this at two different times
scott could you take that to relevant
people and ask yet again
i think we're going to want to make this
consistent and probably all capitals
okay okay
okay but sorry what was your
i was asking about segmentation so so
let's say i take this image here
um and you wanted to manually segment it
or something
i think i need to be you know whatever
so what what
um and i don't understand your label
matrix so that's
is that the new yep
that's a because highlight image takes a
function
runs the function on the image and the
result gets highlighted if you scroll
past that and get to applications that's
a new there's a new
that's a new wait wait that was the
thing the
new is in the first table in the details
the label matrix
is also supported as a new type of
region of interest
okay
and yep that tentative example in
application is a very typical
highlighting that you see from semantic
segmentation algorithms
how does that work i mean so the mask
what is that i don't understand what
that is
table test is the input image what you
see in the background
labeled of mass comma labels
mask is the label matrix and labels
is the list that says sky traffic light
truck and so forth
but does labeled usually do that of
taking a multi-label
i don't think label does that
i've never used it that way so you're
saying if i say labeled
of um i mean i thought if i just did
labeled of a comma one two three
i just get the list one two three as a
label
what is that labeled i don't understand
the multi-label thing
the um i think we are already using that
syntax
in plot for instance plot and list plot
you can
you can have labeled as a wrapper around
your function or the data set
that you're plotting yeah right i
understand that so if i say something
like
labeled
one three seven nine
a b c d
no we don't yeah no we don't
no we don't look at this yes because the
whole list one three seven
nine is one data set and you're labeling
that one data set
with one label abcd okay okay so you're
saying if i have two
data sets
then i don't get any labels at all can
you get rid of d
would that work if the length well if it
is if that's what's going on then that's
a bug
nope it's a bug or it doesn't do what
you think
i think this is a bug because i think
i've wanted this i think i thought that
that worked before so scott that's the
thing for brett please
scott well i'll do it myself then
sorry i was screen grabbing and typing
sure
do you have it yes
um okay
this workflow is clearly way too
complicated
but that's just getting the label matrix
right the addition of highlight image is
pretty straightforward i understand that
but what i'm saying is
you're saying this is a segmentation
mechanism and i'm saying yes this is a
common way of doing segmentation but we
need a better workflow for doing that
right now obviously one thing one thing
there is that the
test image um
just for the sake of saving uh memory in
that notebook
uh julio made that a byte array which is
i think a jpeg
okay that's so that's just wrong so i
mean that will get fixed in the final
version
okay the rest of it we are we we need a
list of labels we are evaluating a
network and we get a label matrix
i understand that i understand it but i
think we need a function called image
segment or something
that does the analog instead of image
cases
right does the thing that produces
the object that can be
that would by default display like this
because this is a very common
type of thing to have a labeled set of
segmentation you know labeled set of
objects in
or we need something that how would you
otherwise do image segmentation with a
network
with a network or without a network with
a network
um isn't this an example of that if you
open the first block
i know but but i'm saying it's way too
complicated yep
well
hence my point right that's just
way way way too complicated what is all
this stuff anyway
it looks like image surgery
net surgery yeah yeah not surgery
right so my point is what we want are
net models that are segmentation models
and then we want them to plug in in some
easy way
okay the the real question is this if i
have a network
and it is segmenting an image what is
the canonical form of its output
we don't have that right now we don't
have a segmented image
as a symbolic object
no label matrix is what we have worked
with since version seven
i know and that's very low level because
it doesn't allow you to have the labels
in the label matrix it just has one two
threes
right so what i'm suggesting given that
this is a popular thing
is that we have some construct that is
something like segmented image
okay so that so that then what you have
is you know if you have segmented image
which would display as something like
this then then what would happen is that
the net model
of whatever it is in that model you feed
it an image
right would return to you a segmented
image which would then immediately
display
yep and that way you know i don't know
what access or functions you need for a
segmented image but that seems like the
right thing
because segmented image would then take
an image
potentially a label matrix or various
other formats here label matrix
arrow labels or something perhaps or a
label matrix and then labels
that are based that would be positional
or you could say
something like um uh you know the label
matrix could have
a b c d in it and that could be an
association as the third argument
this seems like a useful construct to me
well yeah
i i don't disagree at the same time this
might become very similar to
uh image annotations down the road so
potentially this could be an annotated
image
with the label matrix i agree that
segmentation is a very commonly won
attack so maybe we want to make this
specific but post 123
let us try to design
annotations for everything and then come
back to this as well i made a note about
this idea of segmented
segmented image
net encoder to train that net
should be a net encoder for segmentation
and then we should be able to train it
ethan is saying um
ali is asking you specifically shoddy
for component measurements can we
extract the immediate neighbors of a
label
if they share a common boundary um
yes i think component measurements we
added something
just checking brother has four squares
on each on its
on the side separated by one pixel
boundary
can we find the neighbors of the central
square i see what you're asking
um okay
well okay so look i think we'll need a
discussion about annotated image
and i don't i'm i'm you might be right
that annotated image is the right
general wrapper rather than segmented
image
but i think segmented image is an
interesting concept in its own right
i think it is but think of a medical
image don't typically segment the whole
image you
there is a there's a piece that you hone
in on well so fun so that's why the
label matrix i mean that one way to do
it is to have a label matrix the other
way to do it is presumably the bounding
boxes
yeah i mean an alternative form would be
some kind of bounding box
well a region of interest yeah okay
roi arrow label
et cetera
um okay see what else there's there's
clearly a bunch of other things we need
to go over so this is going to take
at least one more meeting unfortunately
um
because we're going to need to go
through the frame fitting stuff and so
on
the bitrate option you're fine with that
we're trying to merge
more of the features into the master for
for the freeze
then you've got to get another meeting
on the books i'm not sure
i don't know it's a very strange name
bitrate
it seems too generic to me
what is it uh it's the number of bits
per second stored for
typically specified separately for audio
and video
um the lower the lower the bit rate
smaller the file but
the poor the quality as well yeah i
don't think it's the right option name
if
it's going to be unless that option name
is also going to be supported
in how do we do throttling in url read
what is the name of the option for that
yep
huh i was sure we had something here
there's
there's some there's some function
which was um
i don't remember where it shows up
maybe it hasn't been released yet uh
who knows about that um
hopeless i mean i don't know whether
that's
um um yeah but anyway
that will be my concern i understand the
concept but i think it has to be applied
uniformly across a bunch of functions
and i think it's a little if it can be
yeah um
asks what will this type of image
segmentation return an
roi mask label matrix that could be
applied to another image or channel
i don't understand how the label matrix
should be applied
to another image
well you for example want to take out
the things that are labeled two
from the other image oh right yes we can
from component measurement we can we can
say
the location of say label five and then
do image value at those positions
pass it the shape or sparse array
whatever comes back
then we can probe another image with
that
okay so ali is commenting that component
measurements doesn't have this
neighbor's functionality so we should
look at that separately there is there
is a series of i just checked there's a
series of neighbors neighbor accounts
and so forth
yeah but it's saying that that it can
give the number of connected neighbors
but not the neighbors themselves
he wants to know
um
and it's a kind of a funky type of
function right because
because you're saying what are the pixel
positions
of the neighbors of this region of
interest
for example neighbors neighbors is the
property of component measures
direct neighbors given as a set of
labels okay okay fine
fine um
okay we should wrap here we're going to
need another one of these hopefully one
hour will be sufficient
and if if you can you know try and get
these like slideshow video and things as
packagings of video of the now not
surviving video
whatever it is frame generator are we
keeping video generator
i don't want to okay we'll look into it
with carl
yeah i don't want to okay um i think
these other things are much more useful
i mean you can keep it as experimental
for another version if you want to but
it's going to go away
okay um
okay an audio generator needs an update
as well but that's a separate issue
which we're obviously not getting two
for twelve three
all